cameroon's president was seen in public
this week for the first time in months
poor beer usually spends a lot of time
out of the country but in recent times
there's been much speculation about his
health and mental fitness
now beer showed up at the annual
national day celebrations in the capital
yeah wunder but this year he didn't give
a state of the nation address which he
usually does the day before
beer has been president of cameroon for
almost 40 years and at 89 he is the
oldest president and the second longest
serving head of state in africa
and with me in studio now is our
reporter from cameroon blaze young blaze
it's good to have you at the table we'll
talk a little bit about your reporting
that's brought you here in a moment but
let's begin
by what we've just seen what do you make
or what are we to make of president beer
not giving his usual speech in the
run-up to national day celebrations
christine you must understand that beer
has always portrayed himself as this
tough guy who does exactly what he wants
only what he wants
secondly there are a lot of speculations
in and out of cameroon about the state
of bias health he's almost 90 years old
in fact is the oldest leader in the
african continent so that doesn't look
so good before this national day
celebration the i was in switzerland
okay blaise let's talk about the
reporting that you've been doing in
cameroon that's also brought here to
germany tell us about that
rights groups have reported abused by
the state security forces and by the
government of president paul b
i have been in rallies i have been in
events in cameroon where people's rights
you would see that people's rights have
been violated so i've spoken to
cameronians in cameroon but i also
wanted to understand what has made so
many convenience to go on exile that is
why i came to germany and here is my
report
now she makes protest videos for social
media
she and her supporters take big risk
speaking out against the government of
poor beer
it is our lives
it is our lives it's our survivor we
don't say because there was an
initiative yesterday we will not do one
today we will do today if this one face
we will do tomorrow and the next day
until we have our fundamental freedoms
and rights as cambodians
she is fighting for freedom of
expression
for democracy for the right to gather
and to protest
at the moment she keep the fight limited
to social media and this compound
she knows she'll be in trouble if she
takes her fight outside
this man took his protest all the way to
cameron's parliament i want to give you
a quote here in this house that i
borrowed from the american liberators
when injustice becomes law
resistance
becomes a duty
the people of west carolina have a duty
to resist your operation
jose weber was an opposition mp
but that species made went viral he says
the authorities threatened him so much
he left
cameroon this week he's meeting other
exiles in germany
this is the first time he did appear in
public
he feels safe now
he has a sign of in the uk
somebody my age
who
had lived all his life in his homeland
because i believed in it
i had so many opportunities in my life
to live and i said i wouldn't
never
and if it wasn't for the fact that i
needed to
get some
get away to save my life i would never
leave it
for people who cannot leave cameroon
staying and protesting can be fatal
rojek ndago was jailed for taking part
in an anti-government protest
he caught cholera in prison and he died
chained to a hospital bed
we could never imagine that this
government will abandon a sick person
chained up in hospital
on the contrary officials who have
embezzled public money are flown abroad
for medical treatment
it is tragic
nowadays being part of the position is a
straight path to death
[Music]
[Music]
kawala keeps our position at home
that might be our best chance to stay in
cameroon
and to stay alive
okay blaise
wow it's a very difficult situation for
people in the opposition in cameroon
um
you've talked about the speculation
around his health president beer is
going to be turning 90 at the at the end
of the year
i mean is there a conversation happening
in in cameroon about what happens
when he goes whenever that will be
one of the characters that we had in our
in our report in the report that we've
just seen the the woman kawala i was
part of a meeting where she organized
with other political uh leaders
and they agreed in this meeting that no
one can uh take bia away through the
violet box so basically the opposition
is preparing for apostia but the problem
is the army has been given so much power
in cameroon for close to 40 years that
beer has been in power he's brought the
army very close to him made them very
comfortable and there are fears that the
army would likely
we cannot say this for certain but
because of how much
power control and
you know they do things sometimes
without consequences this may be the
route that the country may go after bi
is no longer president yeah also
uh there are conflicts uh in the north
in the uh southwest uh and other parts
of cameroon and people different people
are showing interest in becoming
president
in a country where one person has been
president for so long there's certainly
other people who vie for that position
so uh experts that i have i have been
speaking to say
cameron may reach a point where you have
all these people fighting uh to get
someone
at the helm of the country and we
before we round up we we have countries
like um russia you know that has a great
influence in cameron communities just
signed a military cooperation with
russia
russia has been we've seen in other
places where they try to impose a
candidate in a country so that they can
have control
well that's certainly a bleak
outlook in that case then well blaze
thanks so much good to have you in
studio and appreciate that thank you